million questions for you but i want to
get my marvel question just out front
just get it done for fans of marvel when
is the next time bucky will be making an
appearance in the mcu i don't know
per usual i i i can't answer that
question i have
i have no clue but look i i think um i
think it's it's sort of about seeing
what's next for him right i mean to to
some extent we
uh the show i felt really
uh graduated him to another
sort of level of experience and and kind
of you know taking on his past a lot
better and and and it gave him another
sense of place and sense of family that
he's found there with with sam um and um
so he's
in a pretty good spot right now so
we have we have to i guess i i'd be
curious to to see what the next
interesting thing that we could tell
with him would be and and as you well
know
uh there that is above my pay grade
there are there are far wiser
uh
men and women who are making those
decisions sure i've heard there's a lot
of cameos in the dr strange sequel i was
wondering if you were one of them but we
can move on we can
i am not in doctor strange too i promise
i i appreciate that answer so um
in all the first of all congrats on
being part of the 355 um one of the
things that i love is that it's an
all-women
kicking ass team and it sort of reminds
me of like a bond movie in that you know
uh or like a team up movie but you're
one of the the few men in the film so
how did it feel being like the bond guy
if you will do you know what i mean like
yeah i mean i it felt
pretty great
um i was listen uh i was okay taking my
lead off of um
off of them i mean i i
again for me the experience was
such an unbelievable company of actors
to
and women to to be a part of and um
i i knew that it was going to be a very
collaborative experience um
i felt very embraced uh i i felt very
encouraged um uh by jessica as a
producer as well um and simon kimberly
directed it to to
to sort of bring as much to the table as
i could and um it was it was a unique uh
actor-driven experience and and that was
i think her goal
uh with with assembling this
unbelievable company together um and um
and she really wanted the story to be to
be told from a
from the actor's point of view from the
from the creative and uh you just don't
get to do that very often with with this
type of film this type of genre and i
think as a result you get something
that's a little bit different and unique
and more
honest
um you've done now a lot of action and
i'm just curious when you're stepping
into a movie
um whatever it may be like how
do you do you sort of dread the action
do you look forward to doing it because
i know how challenging filming action is
and how time-consuming i only tried it
with anthony uh because um the prom is i
just i have to wait for him for so long
and then it's like
are we gonna get the shot you know but
uh but i i'll tell you one thing i
didn't have to wait on this film
everybody was showing up with their a
game jessica was not holding any punches
um and uh some of them literally did
land
but uh but
yeah i i think
i think action
is a you know is it's sort of this weird
dance that i don't know if it if it
still gets the the credit that it
deserves i mean like take forget about
you know let's not mention the stunt
like stunt teams right who put in the
the level of commitment how they come in
and what they do and how difficult that
is but
you either look good doing it or you
don't like it's not it's not something
that i feel like everybody kind of
learns and and then i think it's so much
about trust and and
it's sort of tedious in a way because
you gotta you have to like really
rehearse it and then finally you have to
forget about it and then you have to
adjust it you know to whatever your
partner is giving you so
um it's it there's a lot that goes into
it and then it sort of looks really cool
and everything and you're like oh
but
yeah it's it's always challenging and
fun you know it's it never gets boring
and the adrenaline is always high
um it's very addictive
yeah i mean i think a lot of people
really don't realize though that you
know some of these action set pieces you
know it's a minute on screen but it took
forever to get that minute filmed and
it's like a complicated dance
it it completely i mean and and
sometimes you have
some of them literally can be a week to
shoot i mean
that fight for example with uh
um
jessica uh
for instance i believe was at least
three days um and there's always
different pieces to it and you have to
go back and
re-watch everything and um
and and it's always about angles because
something can look really good from an
from from a close-up or whatever but
then when you're from here it has to
change
and but if you if you ask the stunt
department they always tell you one
thing you know and that's like if you
can
if you can
fight in a wide
then you really know what you're doing
because you know the close-up is
you don't really see a lot of stuff
i think that's one of the reasons why
everyone loves the john wick movies
because keanu is always in the
unbelievable yeah i mean it's just
unbelievable and one of the reasons why
i'll tell you i'm always going to be
proud of that three three-way fight with
in civil war with evans and um
and iron man because like that we we
knew that was one shot and i was like
we're gonna be in the wide so like
they're gonna see everything like you
really have to get it you can't cheat it
you know
i [ __ ] love that movie
i love that you love it
it's so insane dude it's so good listen
i gotta wrap up just real quick what are
you getting ready to film what's coming
up
i'm i don't um there's nothing really
right now that i can that i can uh talk
about i i it was a i was very lucky to
work on on some very interesting
projects this past year um one one of
them i'm really excited about is that
i'm going to sundance for
uh looks like sundance is still going to
be happening or hopefully or you know um
and um i just yeah i i would
i i can hold back for a second and kind
of
recharge uh because these things believe
it or you know as you as you i'm sure
you suspect the older you get
it's like it especially the action i
mean it takes a lot longer to kind of
come back from it so
let's see
i gotta go thank you so much it's really
great good to see you be safe all the
best you